et quand tu es là tu fais beaucoup
parler de toi et l'année prochaine tu
seras beaucoup plus souvent avec nous ma
chérie et bien vous l'avez compris le
chroniqueur de l'année c'est bien
entendu regardez King
[Applaudissements]
bravo mon Raymond mon frérot je suis
très heureux
je sais que tu es très ému et c'est
compliqué cette année cette année c'est
compliqué Valérie elle a vu aussi parce
que comme j'ai perdu mon papa j'avais
fait le début de la saison où j'allais
j'allais à l'hôpital et je venais ici
après donc c'était très très difficile
on en a parlé aussi ensemble et et il
m'a dit avant de partir il m'a dit reste
avec Hanouna il est gentil avec toi
donc je suis content si me regarde de
là-haut il doit dire au moins il avait
promis quelque part
bravo mon frérot mon rêve mon frérot
d'amour
je dois être fier de toi comme moi je le
suis je sais que je suis fier de toi tu
es mon ami mon frère dans la vie et
c'est vrai que tu étais tu as fait une
annexe exceptionnelle et sache qu'avec
les équipes on t'a écrit une chanson
on t'a écrit une chanson et ce soir
j'aurais demandé à Émilie images de bien
vouloir venir nous rejoindre car c'est
une chanson pour toi ça va être le feu
c'est on a refait les paroles pour
Raymond on va mettre même la mettre en
place pour peut-être la mettre sur des
plateformes etc c'est un tube énorme on
va laisser Emilie et images venez là
merci
merci les chéris c'est énorme parce que
ils ont fait ils ont joué le jeu à fond
et ils ont vraiment enregistré la
chanson ils l'ont fait c'est incroyable
c'est pour Raymond le chroniqueur de
l'année c'est parti chanter chez ma
tante tata 4
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
tout s'arrête pour un transpalette
on peut chanter toujours là
je peux pas sortir
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
au bout de la nuit
[Musique]
quel pervers il regarde une fille qui se
tait
[Musique]
mon petit pour la Nuit Blanche
la nuit blanche
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
qui
regarde
mes pieds
vous disent c'est un gros nickel
il enseigne au bout de la nuit
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
jusqu'à
mon père
[Musique]
merci bravo bravo bravo bravo bravo
merci parce que ils ont joué le jeu
après vous êtes des amours encore 17
décembre 2023 car Arena ils sont tournés
ils font des concerts avec des milliers
de personnes et ils ont joué le jeu
jouet qu'on les appeler
parce que elles ont enregistré tout
merci vraiment merci merci ils étaient à
fond merci vous êtes vraiment des amours
et Raymond et on va et on va la sortir
cela
tu vas faire la tournée des boîtes cet
été ah mais c'est lui c'est sûr ah mais
stop ne touche pas mon pote ben oui et
tu sais l'anecdote ma tante avec
Catherine elle chantait amour sauvage
maîtresse on va ma maîtresse elle
chantait un petit studio et tout elle
voulait à tout près de chanteuse donc si
elle me regarde ta Catherine j'ai chanté
sur votre chanson quand j'étais petit
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]